[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
économie du livre et développement de la
lecture publique de proposition de loi
d'origine sénatoriale
la loi de 1981 sur le prix unique du
livre a été adopté il ya 40 ans
quels instruments de régulation pour est
il aujourd'hui favoriser la présence
d'un réseau de libraires détaillants sur
l'ensemble du territoire et promouvoir
la diversité de la création éditoriale
ainsi que le développement de la lecture
le 24 novembre la commission de la
culture adoptée de proposition de loi
d'origine sénatoriale allant dans ce
sens
la sénatrice laure darcos est à
l'origine de la proposition de loi
visant à améliorer l'économie du livre
et à renforcer l'équité entre ses
acteurs
afin de rétablir une juste concurrence
le texte prévoit notamment de mettre un
terme aux livraisons gratuites d'ouvragé
pratiquées par certaines plateformes au
détriment des libraires
elle vise également à permettre aux
collectivités territoriales de soutenir
leur libraire tout en modernisant et en
élargissant le mécanisme du dépôt légal
numérique
en 40 ans les bibliothèques quand elle
aussi profondément évolué
ces lieux publics représentent
aujourd'hui le 1er équipement culturel
public en france et bénéficie d'un
maillage serré sur l'ensemble du
territoire
on compte 6500 établissements
accueillant environ 12 millions
d'usagers
dans ce contexte la proposition de loi
de sylvie robert relatives aux
bibliothèques et au développement de la
lecture publique vise à conférer enfin
un cadre législatif précis à ces espaces
culturels bâti autour de trois grands
principes la liberté d'accès aux
bibliothèques des communes la gratuité
d'accès à ces institutions enfin le
pluralisme des collections afin de
maintenir la vocation universaliste des
bibliothèques
ces deux propositions de loi d'origine
sénatoriale ont été adoptés à
l'unanimité en séance le 16 décembre
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse des travaux du sénat sur les
deux propositions de loi
[Musique]